being able to film after film tease at a
larger story really building these
stories up into a giant conclusion while
at the same time introducing an entirely
new direction for the future
[Music]
some [ __ ] are always trying to
ice skate uphill there was a little buzz
about maybe a blade four or maybe a
tv-series I mean we unlikely this always
a possibility you know it's a novels
hands and they're controlling the pace
in there and the flow with that as it
comes I've been good they see the value
in it we see the value in it I'm still
in shape enough and fit enough to handle
the roles and so we'll see where it goes
I don't really know what's going to
happen to win it yet maybe in the
Avengers what do you think about bleed
joining the Avengers that'll be
interesting I mean I know it's in the
comic book it'd be interesting to say
where they would place him and where he
really would fit in he's got to bite
somebody I don't know bite someone but I
imagine like overhead shot where they're
just all standing and there you know
collective costuming I feel like you
know you fit right in there and then we
don't have an explosion in the
Apocalypse perfect and and then in the
day Walker survived exactly right you're
the only one that can really make it
through excellent excellent
from your mouth to God's ear everybody
it's Charlie we got to talk about brand
new blade in the Marvel Universe in the
coming years Wesley Snipes has been
teasing more blade recently again
because they have two projects in the
works
a while ago Kevin Feige also confirmed
meetings on the blade project so Wesley
Snipes did a recent interview where he
talked about how this stuff fits into
the Marvel Universe in the actual
projects that he's working on because
you have to remember that blade is a
vampire and right now there are no
vampires in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so this will be an explanation
for the big stuff that he talked about
and then obviously where they would
incorporate that during phase 4 in phase
5 there are a couple easy ways that they
can include him given all the stuff
that's happening with the Disney Fox
deal and all those other x-men IP
characters that they're trying to deal
with in the next couple of years there's
new Infinity Ward giveaway stuff I'll
explain at the end of the video be sure
to subscribe to get everything if you're
brand new to the channel recently Wesley
Snipes said that he has two projects
that he's developed with his own people
and brought to Marvel and they're just
waiting for the right time to slot those
in I'm just gonna read his statement
here so he says there are a lot of
conversations going on right now and
we're very blessed to have enthusiasm
and interest in something coming from
that world again we've created two
projects that fit perfectly into this
world and when people see them I think
they're only gonna have a problem in
deciding which one they love the most
just implying that he feels like they're
both gonna be awesome and people will
just be arguing about which version is
better he goes on to say that all the
execs at Marvel in my team talking about
Kevin Feige and his people we've been
discussing this for the last two years
because it's been in development for a
while everyone's enthusiastic about it
everybody gets it but they get a
business to run and they got to square
the things that they got to figure out
before they can get to it I guess in the
meantime we got a business to run and we
got our own slate of things to do so the
next time you see something in the blade
universe
mark my words what we did before is
child's play compared to what we can do
now so I think you know you look at some
of the grittier films like Logan in the
Deadpool films it just imagined modern
effects in the way that they make movies
with the blade character in that tone of
film like they could just crank
everything up to 11 so it just makes it
a lot easier for Wesley Snipes at the
age he is now because he is quite a bit
older than when the original blade
movies came out to do the Robert Downey
jr. Iron Man thing where he can still be
the blade character and give that
amazing performance but he doesn't have
to kill his body in real life to achieve
that performance I think we're creating
a shadow world where the bridge between
what is reality and the Unreal is very
small it should be pretty obvious that
the two projects that he's referring to
but doesn't specifically explain or a
movie in the Marvel Universe and a TV
series said in the TV Marvel Universe
connected however you want to think
about it because agents of shield is
connected to the movies but you know it
gets into lots of problems there but you
get the idea they just have movie and TV
Blade projects that they're trying to
get out but when he explains that Marvel
isn't quite ready to do stuff like that
it's because like I said vampires don't
exist in the MCU and right now they're
trying to bookend
all the phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 step so
as Feige implied in that clip at the
beginning they're setting the stage
for a bunch of new heroes to enter the
universe that also includes other
characters from the x-men Fantastic Four
Deadpool in now blade universes Wesley
Snipes has actually been trying to get
another blade project going for a long
time now but I think the reason why in
recent years that got accelerated is
because Black Panther blew up so big and
there's such a renewed demand for that
kind of superhero
so if you guys didn't know back in the
90s before he did blade Wesley Snipes
was trying to make a black panther movie
so 90s black panther it never worked out
but remember the 90s flash back in
Oakland at the beginning of black
panther imagine an entire Black Panther
movie set with those characters during
that era there's been a lot of talk
about other actors playing the blade
character in Wesley Snipes becoming the
Whistler character because now he's a
much older person like I said though I
don't think that there are that many
actors that could do the job that Wesley
Snipes did it's like a Robert Downey jr.
Iron Man situation he is that character
even though it's been that long like
there's never gonna be another Tony
Stark
inside the Marvel Cinematic Universe
there might be somebody else that wears
the Iron Man title briefly but there's
always gonna be a Robert Downey jr. Tony
Stark just like Wesley Snipes is always
going to be the Blade character playing
a comic book characters the best of all
worlds because anything goes create a
different voice create a different look
different sound different way of moving
we're talking all stuff very different
from Wesley but even though he's trying
to get an MCU movie made what I'd really
like to see is if they have to wait even
longer to slot him into an MCU film like
even to phase 5 it would be cool to see
him crossover with the venom Sony's
spider-verse
in like a Morbius movie like you do a
blade solo film and you call a blade 4
or whatever then you let him crossover
with some of the other characters that
sort of fit that tone because right now
the only other comic book vampire movie
that's getting made is that Jared Leto
Morbius the living vampire film and
technically that Sony so it would
involve some different sharing
arrangement but remember Marvel has the
rights to blade so giving Sony the
ability to use the blade character in
their universe might incentivize them to
signed they're sharing arrangement with
Tom Hollands spider-man in the MCU the
only Avengers movie I think that they
would ever consider putting blade in
would be like a Secret Wars film where
there's a bunch of stuff going on like
he just doesn't fit with the tone of
what's going on like I love his joke
about biting Scarlett Johansson but what
they might opt to do is if they can't
find a really good way to include him is
that they'll just do the Deadpool thing
because now the Disney owns those
characters Kevin Feige can make a
Deadpool movie if he wants to but it
sounds like their plans are just a leap
Deadpool off in his own universe so even
though Wesley Snipes is pitching in MCU
blade they could just say that this is
all happening in an alternate universe
and just let it be relatively
self-contained but you don't have to
bend over backwards to explain the
continuity all you have to do is say
alternate universe vampires exist they
don't exist in the regular MCU Feige has
said that he won't reveal their complete
phase four plans at least till next year
after Avengers 4 comes out and they
start promoting that the other problem
with the Blade franchise is just like
Deadpool it's rated R and Disney doesn't
release rated R films they might just
make that at Fox or release it through
touchstone or one of their other labels
that does more hardcore films we haven't
quite got there yet Deadpool will be the
best test case for that because they're
definitely gonna make more Deadpool
movies in the next couple of years after
Disney gets the brand let me know in the
comments what do you guys want Kevin
Feige to do with the blade character
given that Wesley Snipes already has a
couple projects ready to go there's a
new round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on the
video I'll name a winner when I post new
Marvel click here for more Avengers 4
and click here to learn what's going on
with that DC streaming service and when
all those shows are launching thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]